eine katastrophe für die menschen ein
desaster für die politik der brand im
griechischen flüchtlingslager moria
macht tausende obdachlos und stellt
drängende fragen an die eu ein gesetz
mit sprengkraft der britische
regierungschef präsentiert seine pläne
für den eigenen binnenmarkt und stellt
damit den br- exit vertrag in frage und
ein sieger mit lust auf mehr
alexander zverev steht als erster
deutscher seit 25 jahren im halbfinale
der us open
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers er mittwochabend bei
ihrem nachrichtenüberblick willkommen
dazu kristin otto kümmert sich nachher
um den sport der genannt tausende
geflüchtete auf der griechischen insel
lesbos haben jetzt auch ihr notdürftiges
dach über dem kopf verloren
das völlig überfüllte flüchtlingslager
moria ist vergangene nacht zu großen
teilen abgebrannt die flammen waren an
mehreren stellen ausgebrochen
jetzt stellen sich viele fragen
insbesondere an die europäische union
und deren flüchtlings und asylpolitik
dazu nachher mehr in der sendung wir
beginnen mit anton kurschilgen und den
ereignissen der nacht auf lesbos
verbrannte hütten zerstörte zelte und
baracken das flüchtlingslager moria
existiert nicht mehr nur noch schutt und
asche da wo tausende flüchtlinge
untergebracht waren
viele haben alles verloren wir haben gar
nichts das drama beginnt in der nacht
die flammen breiten sich rapide aus
angefacht durch starken wind schnell
brennt fast das ganze lager die bewohner
versuchen sich in sicherheit zu bringen
meine hütte da sie ist weg
meine kleidung einfach alles was ich
hatte viele wissen nicht wohin uns
schlafen auf der straße tausende sind
über nacht obdachlos geworden und die
ursache unklar war es brandstiftung
haben anwohner oder flüchtlinge das
feuer gelegt am tag danach wird über
beides spekuliert ob griechenlands
regierung verdichten sich inzwischen die
hinweise dass es flüchtlinge waren
feuerwehrleute berichten dass sie
während der löscharbeiten von migranten
mit steinen beworfen wurden
wir haben es trotzdem geschafft das
feuer so unter kontrolle zu bringen dass
sie sich nicht auf die umliegenden
wälder ausbreiten konnte schon vor dem
feuer standen die lebensbedingungen in
moria in der kritik und es wurde immer
schlimmer
denn das lager stand seit einigen tagen
unter quarantäne weil sich mindestens 35
flüchtlinge mit den corona virus
infiziert hatten
daraufhin gab es unruhen einige
migranten wollten oder verlassen aus
angst sich anzustecken und jetzt haben
auch viele anwohner auf lesbos angst sie
befürchten dass sich das virus auf der
insel ausbreiten könnte niklas fischer
von der hilfsorganisation mission
lifeline ist vor ort auf lesbos im lager
moria genannter fischer wie würden sie
denn die situation jetzt im moment
beschreiben abend ja die situation ist
nach wie vor noch sehr unübersichtlich
sehr chaotisch die leute wären
herumirren herum wissen nicht wo hinten
sie sollen es gibt keine kann den
vernünftigen ansagen oder überhaupt
keine informationen von den behörden
im gegenteil die behörden blockieren
fasst er noch die die arbeit von
hilfsorganisationen
wir sehen hinter ihnen es ist praktisch
alles verbrannt also sicher ist jetzt
schon das wird alles sehr ungewisse
nacht aber gibt es irgendwelche hinweise
darauf wie das dann jetzt in zukunft ja
auch in den nächsten tagen weitergehen
soll für diese menschen das handelt sich
ja immerhin rund 12.000 von ihnen dazu
gibt es leider noch überhaupt keine
informationen ich habe eben noch mit
zwei geflüchteten sprechen können die
mir gesagt haben sie wissen überhaupt
nicht was jetzt passiert wo sie hin
sollen hier alles verloren haben den
rest verloren haben den sie noch hatten
das meiste hatten sie ja leider schon
vorher verloren aber es gibt überhaupt
keine aufklärung keine informationen
jetzt gibt es auch die nachricht dass in
den letzten tagen bereits 35 mindestens
35 flüchtlinge im lager positiv auf
corona getestet wurden
ich kann mir vorstellen dass
verschlimmert die situation noch
zusätzlich wie erleben sie das
also das hat die stimmung insgesamt auf
jeden fall noch stark stark
verschlimmert dass einmal die korona
situation aber vor allen dingen wie die
regierung damit umgegangen ist das
überhaupt keine präventivmaßnahmen
beschlossen wurden nicht umgesetzt
wurden
und als einzige maßnahme um des corona
virus ja wegzuhalten ein großer zaun
gebaut werden sollte sagt niklas fischer
von der hilfsorganisation mission
lifeline in lesbos herzlichen dank herr
fischer danke sagen das gespräch habe
aus technischen gründen kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet moria ist ein ort
des elends mitten in europa und das
schon seit vielen jahren die traurige
geschichte des lagers auf lesbos jetzt
von markus kübler
es sind nur rund 15 kilometer die die
griechische insel lesbos von der türkei
drinnen im oktober 2015 entsteht das
lager moria denn hier verläuft eine der
routen für geflüchtete geplant
eigentlich als durchgangslager auf dem
weg zum festland ab 2016 müssen die
menschen bleiben bis über ein
asylverfahren entschieden ist das dauert
zum teil mehrere jahre nur ja weg zum
grössten flüchtlingslager europas für
2800 menschen gebaut leben zuletzt knapp
12.600 hier darunter 400 unbegleitete
kinder
hilfsorganisationen fordern seit jahren
die schließung gewalt und kriminalität
seien an der tagesordnung und immer
wieder brennt es im märz dieses jahres
stirbt dabei ein sechsjähriges mädchen
es gibt viele die heute sorgen der brand
zeigt auf besonders dramatische weise
wie sehr die migrationspolitik der
europäer gescheitert ist was das für
deutschland konkret bedeutet aber
beginnt die diskussion jetzt wieder neue
los patricia wiedemeier hat diesen
aspekt der geschichte der innenminister
schickte heute sein sprecher vor trotz
der dramatischen ereignisse in moria
hält seehofer daran fest keine weitere
aufnahme von flüchtlingen ohne
europäische lösung
es ist ganz klar dass wir der
griechischen regierung benötigt hilfe
leisten werden
aber das ist kein grund jetzt sozusagen
unsere bisherige rechtsordnung
grundsätzlichen fragen zu stellen
der koalitionspartner spd dagegen
fordert dass seehofer sein verhalten
ändert und flüchtlinge aus moria
aufgenommen werden
ich hoffe dass es jetzt auch zu einem
entsprechenden schritt von seiten von
herrn seehofer durch hoffentlich auch
die unterstützung der bundeskanzlerin
kommt
465 flüchtlinge unbegleitete
minderjährige hat deutschland bisher
aufgenommen nicht genug meint auch die
opposition
mehrere bundesländer allen voran das cdu
fdp regierte nordrhein-westfalen
kündigten zudem an weitere flüchtlinge
bei sich aufnehmen zu wollen wir müssen
gemeinsam sehen dass wir zu einer
europäischen lösung kommen nordrhein
westfalen ist bereit 1000 personen von
besonders gefährdeten direkt auch
aufzunehmen
wir haben jetzt seit monaten seit jahren
kein fortschritt gesehen ja sogar
umgekehrt so dass die bundesregierung
namentlich horst seehofer ist kommunen
und ländern verbietet hilfsbereit zu
sein die bundesregierung muss jetzt und
wenn ich jetzt sage meine ich jetzt ja
ihre politik und ihr verhalten ändern
13.000 leere stühle für die flüchtlinge
vor dem reichstag diese protestaktion
von flüchtlingshelfer ist erst einige
tage her die spd war mit dabei mit dem
heutigen tage wird der druck auf
seehofer sicherlich größer werden und es
gibt fragen an die eu niemand kann sagen
er hätte es nicht gewusst die
verheerenden zustände waren lange
bekannt manche sagen sogar sie wurden
bewusst hingenommen quasi als
abschreckung stefan leifert ist für uns
in brüssel
guten abend stefan wird dieser tag heute
daran etwas ändern also trotz aller
betroffenheit die auch hier in brüssel
herrscht sieht es danach im moment nicht
aus die eu kommission beginnt heute
abend jetzt in den nächsten stunden
immerhin damit die 400 unbegleiteten
minderjährigen flüchtlingskinder zu
evakuieren und aufs festland zu fliegen
aber bei jeder form von hilfe die
darüber hinaus geht beginnt schon wieder
der politische streit deswegen kann man
im moment auch kaum vorhersehen ob es in
den nächsten tagen gelingen wird die
12.000 anderen flüchtlinge die jetzt
ohne obdach auf lesbos sind in den eu
ländern zu verteilen
im moment sieht es danach jedenfalls
nicht aus stefan dahinter steckt ein
grundlegendes problem ist dieser streit
in europa um migrationspolitik überhaupt
zu lösen
zumindest will die eu kommission ende
des monats einen neuen anlauf
unternehmen und ein großes reformpaket
für die europäische asylpolitik
vorstellen sie wagt sich damit an
runde den die mutter aller konflikte in
der eu und will die verteilungsfrage
angehen also die frage gelingt es einen
dauerhaften verteilungsmechanismus zu
etablieren wenn es nicht gelingt länder
wie polen oder ungarn dabei an bord zu
holen dann wäre die gemeinsame
asylpolitik wohl endgültig gescheitert
und so katastrophen wie moria aus der
gestrigen nacht dürften sich wiederholen
stefan vielen dank so viel zunächst zu
diesem thema mehr dazu gibt's gleich
nach uns in einem zdf spezial jetzt noch
ein streitthema in europa eines bei dem
der konflikt heute endgültig eskaliert
mitten in den laufenden drexhage
verhandlungen mit der eu hat
premierminister boris johnson ein gesetz
ins parlament eingebracht das offen
gegen den austritt vertrag verstößt und
gegen internationales recht & johnson
setzt der eu ein ultimatum bis zum 15
oktober müsse eine einigung her sonst
gäbe es einen austritt ohne deal aus
london jetzt andreas stamm eine eher
ungewöhnliche frage für boris johnson
auf dem weg ins parlament brechen sie
gerne das gesetz tue er natürlich nicht
wir erwarten dass jeder im land das
gesetz befolgt der stein des anstoßes
ein gesetzesentwurf am mittag dem
unterhaus vorgelegt die regierung könnte
sich über teile des mit der eu
ausgehandelten austritts abkommens
hinwegsetzen sehr wohl ein gesetzesbruch
erklärt ein minister johnsons schon
gestern spricht internationales recht
auf sehr spezifische und begrenzte art
seit parteifreunde sind mehr als
verwundert nur kleine korrekturen auch
die eu scheint das anders zu sehen am
mittag fordert brüssel erstmals eine
notfallsitzung des gemeinsamen
ausschusses in den streitfragen über das
austritts abkommen zwischen den partnern
geklärt werden
die kommissionspräsidentin twittert
umgehend sie sei sehr besorgt verträge
müssten gehalten werden sonst schwindet
vertrauen und es werde nichts mit guten
künftigen beziehungen
über die der eu chefunterhändler michel
barnier ab heute weiter sprechen will
ankunft in london
wortlos hinter der maske dürfte sich ein
zorniges gesicht verstecken ein ende der
verhandlungen ein brett ohne vertrag
über die künftigen beziehungen rückt mit
großen schritten näher
panik taktik oder die vorbereitung auf
den härtest mögliche exit boris johnson
malt und macht sich gerade die welt wie
sie ihm gefällt was hässlich enden
könnte
in belarus geht präsident alexander
lukaschenko weiter systematisch gegen
die opposition vor
am morgen führten maskierte maxim's 10
ab das letzte noch aktive mitglied des
sogenannten koordinierungsrates zuvor
war schon maria kolesnikova verschleppt
worden eine der anführerinnen der
demokratiebewegung
ihre anwälte sagen sie sitzt in minsk in
u haft der vorwurf versuchte
machtübernahme erste sitzung nach der
sommerpause für die
bundestagsabgeordneten und an
finanzminister olaf scholz gab es gleich
drängende fragen zu hoch umstrittenen
comex geschäften der warburg-bank die
schuldete der stadt hamburg 47 millionen
euro
doch das finanzamt verzichtete warum so
die frage an scholz den ehemaligen
ersten bürgermeister klaus brodbeck
berichtet gleich drei mal muss sich der
vizekanzler
heute erklären morgens im
finanzausschuss zwei stunden dauert die
befragung wir haben uns sehr gut
miteinander unterhalten ich habe mir zur
aufgabe gemacht alle fragen die die
abgeordneten hat diese präzise zu
antworten beantworten und bin auch froh
dass die gelegenheit jetzt endlich
gekommen ist die hamburger privatbank
warburg hatte zu unrecht
steuerrückzahlung und in millionenhöhe
kassiert scholz damals hamburger
bürgermeister hatte sich dreimal mit dem
miteigentümer der bank getroffen aber
zunächst nur ein treffen eingeräumt kurz
danach sollte der bank eine
steuerforderung von 47 millionen
erlassen werden
runde zwei und drei im bundestag scholz
bestreitet sich für die bank eingesetzt
zu haben
die frage ist nicht
wir uns treffen die frage ist wie wir
innerlich eingestellt sind und ob wir
uns davon beeindrucken lassen und
beeinflussen lassen
drei runden dieselben fragen diese
skepsis
natürlich erinnert man sich an dieses
gespräch wenn es aber um viele millionen
euro für die stadt hamburg geht finde
ich das doch bemerkenswert ihm ging es
darum zu betonen dass er mit der sache
nichts zu tun gehabt habe hat er sich
kategorisch festgelegt und das bleibt
für olaf scholz auch die politische
messlatte scholz kanzlerkandidatur macht
die finanzskandale für die politische
konkurrenz interessant für ihn aber
brisant heute war nur ein auftakt
und aus der berliner politik ein
weiteres thema das für heftige
diskussionen sorgt ab ende kommenden
jahres soll schluss sein mit dem
massenhaften töten von männlichen küken
in der legehennen zucht so steht das in
einem gesetzentwurf der landwirtschafts
ministerin
es geht um 45 millionen männliche küken
die in deutschland jedes jahr getötet
werden weil sie keine eier legen
dabei konnten neue verfahren das
geschlecht der küken schon im mai
feststellen männliche tiere müssten also
gar nicht erst schlüpfen
tierschützer kritisieren auch die
neuregelung die übergangszeit sei zu
lang noch zwei wichtige kurzmeldungen
jetzt vor knapp fünf jahren flog die
diesel affäre bei volkswagen auf und
jetzt ist klar
ex konzernchef martin winterkorn muss
sich vor gericht verantworten öffentlich
das braunschweiger landgericht ließ die
anklage wegen betrugs zu wann der
prozess beginnt ist noch offen
und die bundesregierung hat die korona
reisewarnung für fast alle gut 160
länder außerhalb der eu verlängert bis
zum 30 september
dann endet die pauschale warnung und es
wird von land zu land entschieden
auch für spanien gilt ja eine
reisewarnung dort gehen die
infektionszahlen rasant nach oben
in dem ohnehin von der pandemie schwer
getroffenen land im schnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich in
spanien täglich 9100 menschen angesteckt
seit ausbruch der pandemie gab es mehr
als eine halbe million infektionen so
viele wie nirgendwo sonst in europa
die folge hatte beschränkungen
wirtschaftlich leiden besonders
gastwirte die jetzt vehement hilfe
vorlagen christel hass auf ihren masken
steht er rettet die gaststätten es ist
die existenzangst die restaurant und
hotelbesitzer heute in madrid
demonstrieren lässt sie leiden besonders
unter den corona folgen mit
umsatzeinbußen um die 50 prozent
wir vermissen unterstützung und
hilfsbereitschaft für einen sektor der
im sterben liegt paris hat die demo mit
organisiert er sieht schwarz für die
branche denn die regeln werden immer
strikter nur noch die hälfte aller
tische gedacht besetzt werden
das bremst die wirtschaftsleistung und
den konsum und verstärkt die ohnehin
große angst der menschen die rasant
steigenden corona fälle verschlimmern
die situation die touristen bleiben aus
viele restaurants und hotels schließen
über eine million arbeitsplätze sind in
gefahr auch die kanaren die noch auf
gäste unter anderem aus deutschland
gezählt hatten sind jetzt risikogebiet
viele buchungen wurden storniert die
hotel pools sind verwaist eine
hiobsbotschaft
genau davor haben die hoteliers uns
besonders gefürchtet viele werden dicht
machen wie zum beispiel schließen schon
diese woche dass er mal vor corinna
schützen und gleichzeitig die wirtschaft
stützen spanien steht vor einer fast
unlösbaren aufgabe bei uns in
deutschland ist die zahl der gemeldeten
neuinfektionen weiterhin deutlich
niedriger als in spanien im durchschnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 1200 80 menschen mit dem virus
angesteckt gestern waren es 1200 60
weltweit wird an einem impfstoff gegen
das corona virus mit hochdruck geforscht
jetzt ein rückschlag der britisch
schwedische pharmakonzern astrazeneca
hat seine klinische studie erstmal
gestoppt in der dritten und letzten
phase der grund es gibt bei einer
testperson gesundheitliche probleme ob
es sich um nebenwirkungen des impfstoffs
handelt wird geprüft das unternehmen
spricht von einer routinemaßnahme ganz
viel passiert heute in der welt jetzt
gucken wir auf die welt des sports und
das macht christian becker vor 25 jahren
in deutschlands aktuell bester
tennisprofi alexander zverev bleibt bei
den us open in new york in der
erfolgsspur und sichert sich nach
beherztem kampf über dreieinhalb stunden
den einzug in die vorschlussrunde in
vier sätzen gegen den kroaten coach fast
ungläubig schweres blick nach metz ball
erstmals im halbfinale der us open nach
sie gegen einen seiner angstgegner an
einem tag an dem längst nicht alles rund
läuft für den weltranglisten-siebten
nach 1 zu 6 im ersten satz hat bereits
alles an seine schmerzhafte us-open-
niederlage gegen george vor drei jahren
erinnert dort wäre bleibt ruhig und
dreht die partie zweimal im tie break
und im vierten satz durch diesen
spektakulären passierball zum
vorentscheidenden break manchmal ist man
halt nicht irgendwie immer ein top form
an das wichtigste ist trotzdem weg zu
finden
dass er ihnen fand zeugt vom
reifeprozess den der 23-jährige
durchgemacht hat im halbfinale trifft er
am freitag auf den spanier pablo carino
booster und bereits im finale laura
siegemund aus metzingen
doppel als erster deutscher seit claudia
kohde kilsch vor 35 jahren auf wen sie
nun im endspiel am freitag mit der
russin vera swonarewa trifft steht noch
nicht fest
und zur tour de france elfte etappe
knapp 170 kilometer weg von der
atlantikküste richtung partie fast
durchweg flach und wie erwartet erneut
mit einer massenankunft schnellster im
sprint der australier kelle billion ganz
rechts sein zweiter etappenerfolg der
mann in gelb bleibt der slowene primoz
publik
das triple mit dem fc bayern münchen ist
sein bisher größter erfolg auf
fußballvereins ebene
und so präsentierte hansi flick fröhlich
alle drei pokale im vereinsmuseum
beendete aber gleichzeitig die euphorie
um rekordmeister in dem er sagte wir
haben alle ziele erreicht wir haben auch
gefeiert aber jetzt ist es vorbei
tja in neun tagen es bundesliga-auftakt
hat das will ich gesagt jetzt ist es
vorbei
lukas dabei habe ich jetzt noch die
lottozahlen zum beispiel die können uns
gemeinsam angucken und sie lauten 9 22
24 35 46 49 superzahl 9 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de note im
zdf text auf seite 55 7 die superzahl
lautet 0
das muss noch mal richtig machen 0 ist
die superzahl
dann kommen wir zum wetter noch mehr
sommer in den kommenden tagen details
gleich von präsident ali ich empfehle
das heute journal mit bettina schausten
sie hat fragen zur flüchtlingspolitik an
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet von
uns war es das jetzt gleich weiter mit
dem zdf spezial und in allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]